okay so how do you want to cover nested
information I mean it's not too tricky
you know what let's use object literal
notation here you could accomplish the
same thing using dot or bracket notation
but I want to show the students a really
useful tool for making sure your data
are formatted properly which relies on
object literal notation so you mean JSON
yep JavaScript object notation hey James
you had two majors right let's make it a
JSON object that shows nested data okay
so I'm seeing one big object with one
property called schools in schools is a
list of two objects we know it's a list
because we have these square brackets
here indicating it's in a write the
first object has the name eckerd college
city of saint pete and so on the second
object has a name of Nova Southeastern
in the city of Fort Lauderdale this
looks like a good JSON to me you mind if
we check it not at all